i believe in freedom of speech i believe
in the right to
be allowed to have an opinion if i have
to fall on my sword for expressing an
honestly held opinion
so be it piers morgan is demanding that
the talk
apologized to his friend sharon osborne
after he says she was quote shamed and
bullied into apologizing for defending
him
i think we should stop this and don't
try and cry because if anyone should be
crying it should be me right now i'm
talking to
a woman who i believe is my friend and i
don't want anybody
here to to watch this
and say that we're attacking you for
being racist
i think it's too late i think that feeds
already
let me get you up to speed on tuesday
piers quit
good morning britain after receiving
backlash for his comments about meghan
markle following her sit-down with oprah
winfrey
i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
says meghan markle
shortly after itv announced his exit
sharon came to his defense on twitter
writing quote
people forget that you're paid for your
opinion and that you're just speaking
your truth
well that tweet landed sharon in some
hot water
and on wednesday's episode of the talk
her co-host tried to explain why people
were upset
when we kind of give passes or give
space to people
who are who are being who are saying
damaging harmful things
what we're kind of doing is permissing
it and i think that's what people are
reacting to
and while the women of the daytime talk
show barely addressed the heated debate
on thursday's show
we are a tv family here sometimes we
argue like we did yesterday and
sometimes we laugh
but we are back together again today
sharon
did issue a lengthy statement on
instagram
apologizing to anyone she might have
offended adding that she will continue
to learn
listen and do better i hope we can all
hold each other up with accountability
compassion and love during this powerful
time of paving the way for so much
needed change
if people want to believe meghan markle
that's entirely their right
i don't believe almost anything that
comes out of her mouth
and i think the damage she's done to the
british monarchy
and to the queen at a time when prince
philip is lying in hospital
is enormous and frankly contemptible
shortly after sharon issued her apology
piers responded via twitter and demanded
an apology from the talk
writing quote sharon's been shamed and
bullied into apologizing for defending
me
against colleagues accusing me of racism
because i don't believe meghan markle's
bullsh
this is where we've reached i demand an
apology from those to talk bullies for
their disgraceful slurs against
me my opinions remain my opinions they
can't silence that